listen to this tell me what is it you
plan to do with your one wild and
precious life
don't you want to be fully awake your
soul ignited by a purpose oh I'm serious
that again
world champion Marathon swimmer this one
I want to do is 60 hours that's Cuba to
Florida
absolutely not no no no that's insane
Diana you tried that when you're 28 and
you did not make it when you're 28
you're 60. I don't believe in imposed
limitations the only one who gets to
decide if I'm through is me
okay
it's 100 miles
for 60 hours of constant swimming
like what I'm most afraid of is sharks
and man of war
I just know I can do it and I couldn't
do it without you ah all right okay
everything's got a little what you want
to do it's never been done I'm
especially not for a woman
especially not for someone your age
I gotta breathe Diana breathe down
four tries and four failures
you really don't get it do you you don't
even think of me of course I think about
you I watched you die
you know this isn't about you okay this
is about me for once
imagine knowing you could do something
that no one else could do
I think we have a window
Diana is back
I know the world wants me to shut my
mouth and sit down and wait to die but I
can't
live
there's no one more naive than you
[Music]